merci merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Claude goasgen
pour les
républicains
merci ma question s'adresse au Premier
ministre et plus particulièrement au
Premier ministre deuxè personnage de la
République qui est son rang
protocolaire monsieur le Premier
ministre monsieur le Premier ministre 2è
oui 2è monsieur le Premier ministre nous
avons subi deux affronts pendant cette
campagne électorale
un homme imminent de la République qui
aujourd'hui vient de déserter son bureau
a osé proférer des insultes graves qui
sont d'ailleurs du domaine pénal tant de
l'injure publique que de la diffamation
à l'égard d'une candidate ces propos
sont des incitations à la haine raciale
en accusant madame PC de favoriser la
race blanche ses propos sont pénalement
à
poursuivre monsieur le Premier ministre
nous avons cette deuxième insulte de
voir que le président de l'Assemblée
nationale n'a pas eu le courage devant
l'hémicycle de venir s'expliquer mais je
voudrais vous dire à vous qui être le
représentant de la République le plus
haut après le président et qui est
chargé aussi d'une Bolle morale des
institutions comment Monsieur le Premier
Ministre n'avez-vous pas réagi pourquoi
avez-vous approuvé par votre silence
voire même d'ailleurs par au propos
quelque chose qui était purement
infamant pour la 5e République alors
Monsieur le Premier Ministre ma question
est simple est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
allez sortir de la campagne électorale
et vous tenir comme le deuxième
personnage de l'État en condamnant les
propos du président de
[Applaudissements]
l'Assemblée la parole est à Monsieur le
Premier
[Applaudissements]
Ministre madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Député
Gog vous nous vous inviter à sortir de
la campagne électorale sortez vous-même
de cette campagne
électorale
les les Français c'était dit tout à
l'heure ont voté au cours de ces deux
derniers dimanches ils ont donné je
crois même s'il faut être
particulièrement lucide une force à la
démocratie par leur participation et
leur choix de barrer la route à
l'extrême droite et moi je préfère
monsieur aujourd'hui me féliciter pardon
vous auriez d'ailleurs pu le rappeler en
parlant de polémique et de débat au
cours de cette campagne et notamment
après le premier tour me féliciter une
nouvelle fois de l'attitude des
responsables de la gauche qui par leur
attitude dans le Nord Calais Picardie
dans le Grand Est en PACA ont permis à
Xavier Bertrand à Philippe Richer et à
Christian
estrozi d'être élu il n a aucune
manipulation c'est un rappel et la
deuxième remarque que je voudrais faire
monsieur goasg c'est que
précisément ce que les Français ne
veulent plus c'est de ce genre de séance
c'est de ce genre de polémique c'est
aller rechercher en permanence la
division alors Monsieur goasgen les
polémiques elles sont derrière nous
Claude Bartelone encore dit ce qu'il
fallait dire ce matin sur le sujet il
est président de l'Assemblée nationale
et invite chacun à respecter précisément
les institutions les uns et les autres
et plutôt qu'à chercher la polémique
absurde et répéter à nous respecter et
uvrer pour les Français ce qu'ils
attendent de nous c'est ça et pas ce
genre de débat et de polémiques ces
polémiques elles sont derrière nous
monsieur goasgen laissezle derrière nous
et soyons encore une fois à la hauteur
de ce qu'attendent les Français et moi
je veux ici répéter une nouvelle fois
mon soutien et ma confiance en Claude
Bartelone
merci Monsieur le Premier
Ministre s'il vous plaît